un análisis de semen es un examen que
mide la cantidad y la calidad del
líquido reproductivo de un hombre
denominado semen y de sus células
reproductivas denominadas
espermatozoides
el aparato reproductor del hombre
incluye dos glándulas denominadas
testículos o test test
se encuentran dentro de una bolsa de
piel denominada escroto
el escroto está fuera del cuerpo y
mantiene los testículos lo
suficientemente frescos como para
generar espermatozoides conectada a cada
testículo hay una masa de tubos en
espiral denominada epidídimo
cada epidídimo almacén espermatozoides
inmaduros mientras éstos continúan
desarrollándose durante una relación
sexual el espermatozoide viaja a través
de un tubo adherido al epidídimo
denominado conducto deferente hacia otro
tubo denominado conducto eyaculatorio
allí el espermatozoide se mezcla con el
líquido de dos glándulas denominadas
vesículas seminales así como también con
el de la glándula prostática esta
combinación de líquidos ahora denominada
semen sale del cuerpo a través de la
uretra el tubo dentro del pene que
normalmente transporta la orina
durante el coito este proceso denominado
eyaculación deposita semen en la vagina
de la mujer
el semen contiene decenas de millones de
espermatozoides en la vagina los
espermatozoides pueden pasar a través
del cuello uterino del útero y de las
trompas de falopio para fertilizar un
óvulo del cuerpo de la mujer
la fertilización del óvulo representa el
inicio del desarrollo del ser humano
durante el embarazo el médico puede
recomendar un análisis de semen a un
hombre si él no es capaz de embarazar a
una mujer después de un año de tener
relaciones sexuales sin protección como
mínimo o después de seis meses y ya
tiene más de 40 años o si se realizó un
procedimiento de control de natalidad
denominado vasectomía el examen puede
realizarse para constatar que no haya
espermatozoides en el semen
para el análisis de semen el hombre debe
proporcionar una muestra de semen
obtenida después de un periodo de dos a
cinco días sin eyacular en general los
hombres recolectan el semen en un frasco
o tarro estéril después de estimularse
para eyacular un acto denominado
masturbación y el médico puede
proporcionar un condón especial para que
se recoja el semen en la casa durante el
coito
es importante recolectar todo el semen
eyaculado
las muestras recolectadas en el hogar
deben mantenerse a temperatura corporal
y deben llevarse al laboratorio dentro
de las dos horas para obtener resultados
fiables en el laboratorio la persona que
analiza el semen observará el volumen o
la cantidad total de la muestra de semen
el intervalo normal de volumen es de 1 y
medio a 5 mililitros o aproximadamente
un tercio de una cucharadita a una
cucharadita si el volumen de semen es
muy bajo es probable que no tenga muchos
espermatozoides o suficiente líquido
para nutrir y transportar los
espermatozoides hasta el óvulo de una
mujer en el laboratorio también se
observa la consistencia del semen
si el cenan es demasiado espeso el
espermatozoide quedará atrapado en este
a continuación
se realizan tres exámenes principales en
la muestra de semen con un microscopio
primero un examen denominado recuento de
espermatozoides mide la cantidad de
espermatozoides por mililitro de semen
si el conteo es demasiado bajo reduce
las posibilidades de que una mujer quede
embarazada en segundo lugar un examen de
motilidad analiza la manera en la que se
mueven o nadan los espermatozoides si
los espermatozoides tienen una utilidad
deficiente
nada muy lentamente no nadan de forma
adecuada o directamente no se mueven con
una motilidad deficiente es probable que
el espermatozoide no pueda nadar hasta
el óvulo de una mujer para fertilizar lo
en tercer lugar un examen de morfología
analizará la forma del espermatozoide un
espermatozoide con una morfología
anormal puede tener una forma que causa
una motilidad deficiente o es probable
que el espermatozoide no pueda
fertilizar el óvulo aún si llega a él